Termin „kwantowa teleportacja" może brzmieć jak science fiction, ale jak omówimy w dzisiejszym odcinku
Qiskit in the Classroom, to bardzo realna i bardzo użyteczna technika dla kwantowej komunikacji i
sieci. Witaj w Qiskit in the Classroom. W tej serii używamy Qiskit, by badać pewne fundamentalne
koncepcje powszechnie omawiane na kursach związanych z quantum computing. Każdemu filmowi towarzyszy interaktywny moduł
zlinkowany w opisie poniżej, więc koniecznie go sprawdź. Teleportacja to trochę trop z science fiction i fantasy.
Osoba lub obiekt znika z jednego miejsca i natychmiast pojawia się gdzieś indziej.
Choć byłoby to fajne, niestety ten rodzaj teleportacji jest niemożliwy. Złamałoby to kosmiczny
limit prędkości. Nic nie może poruszać się szybciej niż światło. Ale kwantowa teleportacja jest
możliwa. Przy kwantowej teleportacji informacja – a nie materia – może być przesyłana między dwiema
odległymi lokalizacjami. Potrzebujesz tylko pary splątanych cząstek – po jednej w każdym miejscu – i sposobu komunikowania informacji klasycznej
między tymi miejscami. Protokół ten opracowano w 1993 roku przez zespół
naukowców kwantowych, w tym Charlesa Bennetta z IBM. Nazwali to kwantową teleportacją, bo podobnie jak w wersji
fikcyjnej, informacja kwantowa znikała z jednej lokalizacji i pojawiała się w innej, odległej
lokalizacji, nie przebyłszy pośredniego obszaru. Może to brzmieć jak magia, ale jak zobaczymy, nie ma
w tym nic tajemniczego ani magicznego. Jest to możliwe dzięki zjawisku splątania kwantowego oraz klasycznej
komunikacji. Dzisiaj przejdziemy przez protokół kwantowej teleportacji i to, jak działa. A potem
wcielimy go w życie na prawdziwym komputerze kwantowym, teleportując stan qubitu z jednej strony procesora kwantowego IBM na
drugą. Oto jak działa kwantowa teleportacja. Załóżmy, że mamy dwie osoby: Alice i Boba, rozdzielonych
dużą odległością. Powiedzmy, że Alice ma qubit. Nazwijmy go qubit Q dla wygody. Jest on w pewnym
nieznanym stanie kwantowym sq, gdzie alpha_0 i alpha_1 są liczbami
zespolonymi. Alice chce wysłać swój stan do Boba, ale nie ma możliwości wysłania samego qubitu. Może on
być zbyt daleko albo może nawet nie wie dokładnie, gdzie jest Bob, więc nie wie, gdzie go wysłać. Na szczęście
przyjaciele już dzielą parę splątanych qubitów A i B, gdzie Alice ma qubit A, a Bob ma qubit B.
Te qubity są splątane. Przez splątane rozumiem, że choć dwa qubity są rozdzielone dużą
odległością, ich stany są skorelowane w sposób, którego fizyka klasyczna nie może wyjaśnić. Ta splątana para to
tak zwany ebit, który możemy wykorzystać jako zasób w quantum computing i komunikacji.
W tym przypadku Alice może użyć ebitu jako zasobu do przesłania swoich informacji kwantowych do Boba. Żeby zobaczyć jak, zacznijmy
od zapisania wspólnego stanu wszystkich trzech qubitów, gdzie uszeregowałem qubity nieco arbitralnie
w tym miejscu, ale ta kolejność będzie wygodna, gdy uruchomimy eksperyment w Qiskit. W Qiskit standardowym sposobem
porządkowania qubitów jest od prawej do lewej. Stan qubitu zero pojawia się więc po prawej stronie.
Rozwinijmy trochę stan i przepiszmy go tak. Pierwszym krokiem w naszym protokole teleportacji jest
splątanie przez Alice jej qubitu danych z jej połową ebitu za pomocą bramki C-NOT. Bramka C-NOT, czyli sterowana NOT,
zmienia stan jednego qubitu – qubitu docelowego – w zależności od stanu innego qubitu – qubitu sterującego.
Jeśli qubit sterujący jest w stanie zero, nic nie dzieje się z docelowym. Jeśli qubit sterujący jest w
stanie jeden, qubit docelowy jest odwracany. W tym przypadku qubit danych Q Alice będzie qubit sterującym, a
jej qubit ebitu A będzie qubit docelowym. Pierwsze dwa wyrazy nie zmieniły się wcale pod wpływem C-NOT, ale
dwa ostatnie tak, bo qubit sterujący Q był w stanie jeden. Następnie Alice
stosuje bramkę Hadamard do swojego qubitu danych Q, która przenosi stan 0 do stanu 1/2 (0 + 1), a stan 1
do 1/2 (0 - 1). Pominę tu trochę prostej algebry, którą możesz spróbować uzupełnić samodzielnie, jeśli chcesz.
Po przestawieniu niektórych wyrazów dostaniesz stan wyglądający tak. Trój-qubitowy
splątany stan Alice i Boba wygląda jak kompletny bałagan. Ale popatrz, co się dzieje, gdy Alice mierzy oba swoje qubity. Trój-qubitowy
stan częściowo się spada do jednego z tych czterech
wyrazów. W każdym przypadku Bob zostaje ze stanem superpozycji z amplitudami powiązanymi z nieznanym
wyjściowym stanem Alice. Pamiętaj, amplitudy to alpha_0 i alpha_1. Na przykład,
jeśli Alice zmierzy oba qubity jako zero, stan Boba spadnie do tego wyrazu – oryginalnego
nieznanego stanu, który Alice chciała teleportować. Ale jeśli Alice zmierzy zero na qubicie A i jeden na qubicie Q, to stan Boba
będzie ten. Ten stan można przekształcić w oryginalny stan qubitu Q, jeśli Bob
zastosuje bramkę Z, która odwróci ten znak tutaj. Ale Bob nie będzie wiedział, żeby to zrobić,
dopóki nie dowie się, co zmierzyła Alice. Następnym krokiem w protokole jest więc to, żeby Alice zadzwoniła do Boba i powiedziała mu,
co zmierzyła. Gdy już to wie, będzie wiedział, jakie operacje wykonać na swoim qubicie, żeby pasował do
oryginalnego stanu Alice. Oto tabela czterech możliwych pomiarów i czterech możliwych operacji, które Bob
musi wykonać na swoim qubicie na podstawie tych pomiarów. Bob może potrzebować zastosować bramkę Z, bramkę X lub obie,
żeby przekształcić swój qubit tak, by pasował do oryginalnego qubitu Alice. Ten ostatni krok, gdy Alice dzwoni do Boba, nawiasem mówiąc, to dlatego
kwantowa teleportacja nie narusza przyczynowości. Choć stan Boba natychmiast się zapadł, gdy Alice zmierzyła
swoje qubity, Bob nie mógł uzyskać żadnych informacji z tego stanu, dopóki Alice nie powiedziała mu, co zmierzyła. A
ta rozmowa była ograniczona prędkością światła. Przeszliśmy przez dużo szczegółowej matematyki, więc niesamowity fakt,
że właśnie teleportowaliśmy informację kwantową, mógł umknąć. Ale naprawdę jest to niesamowite. Używając
splątania jako zasobu, Alice mogła dokonać pomiaru, niszcząc informację kwantową u siebie i sprawiając, że pojawi się
w innej odległej lokalizacji u Boba. Ta odległość mogłaby wynosić setki, a nawet tysiące kilometrów. Co jeszcze bardziej
zdumiewające, protokół ten nie wymaga nawet, żeby Alice wiedziała dokładnie, gdzie jest Bob. Dopóki dzielą ebit
i mogą klasycznie ze sobą komunikować, kwantowa teleportacja zadziała. Zobaczmy teraz, jak to działa
WEBVTT
w Qiskit i faktycznie teleportujmy stan kwantowy na komputerze kwantowym.
Zaczniemy od trzech qubitów – po jednym dla qubitu danych Q i qubitów A i B tworzących ebit.
Zaczynamy od tworzenia ebitu. Stosujemy Hadamard na qubicie A, a następnie C-NOT
między A i B, żeby utworzyć szukany stan splątany.
Następnie przygotowujemy qubit Q Alice w losowym stanie kwantowym, stosując losową unitarną pokazaną przez to pudełko oznaczone
U. Potem następuje teleportacja. Najpierw C-NOT między qubitami Q i A. Potem Hadamard na
qubicie Q. Potem pomiary częściowo zawalają stan, tak że tylko qubit B Boba jest w superpozycji.
To jest moment, gdy Alice dzwoniłaby do Boba i mówiła mu, co zmierzyła. Bob następnie stosowałby
pewne bramki w zależności od tych pomiarów. Te czerwono obramowane pudełka oznaczają bramki warunkowe. Pierwsze oznacza,
że Bob stosuje bramkę X do swojego qubitu, jeśli qubit A zmierzono jako jeden.
Drugie – że stosuje bramkę Z, jeśli qubit Q zmierzono jako jeden.
Teraz Bob powinien mieć qubit w tym samym stanie, w jakim był qubit Alice w tym miejscu, po bramce unitarnej.
Jeśli wszystko poszło zgodnie z planem, teleportowaliśmy stan kwantowy. Ale jak to sprawdzić? Możemy uruchomić
ten sam circuit, ale z jedną małą zmianą.
Tutaj dodaliśmy kolejną unitarną na samym końcu circuit, stosowaną do qubitu Boba. Ta unitarna jest odwrotnością
tej zastosowanej na początku do qubitu Alice. Rozumowanie jest takie: jeśli ta pierwsza bramka stworzyła
stan kwantowy, który jest teraz teleportowany do qubitu Boba, to ta powinna go cofnąć, przywracając qubit Boba do stanu zero.
Oczywiście to niweczy całą naszą pracę teleportacji. Nie chcielibyśmy tego robić,
gdybyśmy faktycznie chcieli coś zrobić z teleportowanym stanem i gdyby był naprawdę w nieznanym stanie kwantowym,
nie bylibyśmy w stanie zastosować unitarnej, by to cofnąć. W każdym razie, to jest czysto diagnostyczne –
upewniamy się, że teleportacja się powiodła. Jeśli zmierzymy qubit Boba jako stan zero, możemy być w miarę
pewni, że teleportacja zadziałała. Gdy będziemy pewni, że protokół działa zgodnie z oczekiwaniami, możemy usunąć tę
końcową unitarną i faktycznie coś zrobić z teleportowanym stanem. Ale na razie upewnijmy się tylko, że działa.
Uruchommy circuit na komputerze kwantowym. Możemy użyć prymitywu Qiskit sampler, by uruchomić ten circuit
wiele razy i zebrać statystyki o wynikach pomiarów. Gdybyśmy teleportowali stan Alice do Boba doskonale za każdym razem,
Bob mierzyłby swój qubit jako zero za każdym razem. Ale ze względu na szum środowiskowy i niedoskonałości
bramek można oczekiwać pewnych przebiegów, gdy qubit Boba skończy jako jeden. Ale dopóki przez większość
czasu qubit Boba jest mierzony jako zero, możemy uznać to za sukces. Oto histogram wyników pomiarów
wszystkich trzech qubitów. Pomiar Boba pokazany jest na pierwszym miejscu każdego trzycyfrowego ciągu. Zgodnie z oczekiwaniami cztery
wyniki odpowiadające jego bitu jako zero są znacznie bardziej prawdopodobne niż pozostałe cztery. Więc pomyślnie
teleportowaliśmy stan kwantowy. Ale spójrz, jak daleko teleportowaliśmy. To jest mapa wszystkich
qubitów na procesorze kwantowym, którego użyliśmy. W eksperymencie użyliśmy właśnie tych trzech qubitów.
Qubit Alice był tutaj, a qubit Boba tutaj. Były więc niemal obok siebie. Moglibyśmy
osiągnąć to samo, stosując kilka bramek swap, które – jak sama nazwa wskazuje – zamieniają stany kwantowe
dwóch sąsiednich qubitów. Kwantowa teleportacja jest użyteczna do transportu informacji kwantowej na duże odległości,
a stany kwantowe były już teleportowane na setki kilometrów. W naszych eksperymentach jesteśmy ograniczeni rozmiarem
chipa, ale moglibyśmy uczynić teleportację nieco bardziej imponującą, teleportując stan między dwoma
odległymi qubitami na naszym komputerze kwantowym. Spróbujmy więc. Oto nasz nowy diagram circuit. Wygląda nieco bardziej
skomplikowanie, ale nic się fundamentalnie nie zmieniło, poza tym że teraz Alice i Bob tworzą swój wspólny ebit,
a potem się rozdzielają. Ta seria linii i X-ów reprezentuje bramki swap, które przenoszą
stany Alice i Boba z jednego qubitu na inny. Alice przesuwa się do qubitu 1,
a Bob do qubitu 12. Następnie Alice tworzy swój losowy stan na qubicie 0 za pomocą
tej unitarnej. Pamiętaj, że tworzy stan po tym, jak ona i Bob już się
rozdzielili. Bob jest już daleko od niej.
Następnie protokół teleportacji przebiega jak wcześniej i Bob kończy z oryginalnym stanem Alice po swoich
operacjach warunkowych. Stosujemy odwrotną bramkę unitarną i sprawdzamy, czy qubit Boba jest
w stanie zero. I znowu widzimy, że przez większość czasu qubit Boba był w stanie zero.
Teleportacja więc się powiodła.
Wskaźnik sukcesu nie jest jednak tak wysoki jak wtedy, gdy Alice i Bob byli obok siebie. Wszystkie te bramki swap
mogą być kosztowne i powodować pewną degradację ebitu. Kwantowa teleportacja może wydawać się magią, ale jak
widzieliśmy, potrzeba tylko splątania, klasycznego kanału komunikacji i nieco sprytu. Oryginalny protokół z 1993 roku,
który omawialiśmy w tym filmie, stanowi fundament dla innych protokołów, takich jak kwantowa teleportacja gate,
i jest niezbędnym składnikiem obliczeń i komunikacji kwantowej.
Na froncie eksperymentalnym naukowcy nadal przesuwają granice kwantowej teleportacji, nawet teleportując
stan kwantowy fotonu między laboratorium na Ziemi a satelitą oddalonym o 1400 km
powyżej. I teleportując stany kwantowe przez zaszumiony klasyczny kabel internetowy. Jeśli chcesz sam teleportować swój
stan kwantowy, zajrzyj do modułu kwantowej teleportacji zlinkowanego w opisie poniżej. Dzięki za oglądanie
i do następnego razu.